hey guys I want to do a video on hair
loss due to hormones so many people
don't ask themselves what causes the
hair loss they just start taking
something without understanding that
there's a cause-and-effect relationship
and we get two hormones it's huge and
it's complex I'll try to make it really
simple for you but there's about six
scenarios that you could run into
relating to hormones I'll put some links
down below of what to do for each
situation and as I go through this just
make mental notes on what thing might
apply to you okay so the first thing is
cortisol that relates to stress low
cortisol is where you have this major
loss situation you go through this
stress or a shock to the body and you
lose your immune system and you get
autoimmune so you have alopecia okay so
that's a hair patches coming out because
of low cortisol if cortisol is high it
destroys your protein so you can have
high cortisol or low cortisol and add
hair loss but usually if it's high it's
like it's just general hair loss it's
not patches okay so that's cortisol
estrogen when the estrogen goes higher
as compared to during a pregnancy or
maybe you have estrogen dominance going
through your period or you're taking
birth control pills well what's going to
happen is that your thyroid is going to
be inhibited so increase estrogen
decrease thyroid function hair loss okay
and then postpartum pregnancy so you had
a pregnancy else and you've lost your
hair what happens in that situation is
you drop the estrogen and that
automatically indirectly increases the
testosterone so now we're end up with
this high testosterone which then turns
to a very powerful testosterone called
DHT burns out your hair okay I put a
link down and what what to take for that
if that happened to you and then insulin
insulin can convert to a male hormone
called an dojin's okay and that's in a
condition called polycystic ovarian
syndrome where you have this facial hair
but then you lose all the hair up there
so that's the situation because it
insulin converts
to antigen and I have a video a lots of
videos on estrogen I'm sorry insulin and
what to do about it how to fix it it's
kind of like a pre-diabetic situation if
you have insulin resistance or you're
diabetic you need to watch those videos
okay then we get to menopause menopause
is when your estrogen decreases but the
opposing hormone doesn't decrease as
much that's called testosterone so we
have low estrogen higher testosterone
DHT hair loss same situation with with
this one we just talked about okay
that's during menopause and then having
just a thyroid problem in general
hypothyroidism you can lose your hair
and the outer eyelash I browse right
here and usually the deeper cause of
thyroid are mainly a liver or
gallbladder problem and you can't
convert the thyroid hormones or it could
just be high levels of estrogen we
talked about that over here causing the
blockage of the thyroid okay so that's
the thyroid connection and then just
testosterone when you increase
testosterone you increase DHT and what
happens is DHT burns out the hair
follicles so there's a very simple
solution to this show you down in the
link down below and what will cause
increase testosterone if your female is
increased insulin because you have
insulin resistance and you crave sugar
and you're eating too much sugar or you
have lowered amounts of estrogen if
you're a female and indirectly you're
going to always have the higher levels
of testosterone okay little complex
video but I wanted to give you all the
scenarios that are involved in hair loss
with hormones see which one indicates
watch the video below so it we can just
make it simple thanks for watching
press the subscribe button press it
forget it forget it undone press the
subscribe button and I will keep you
updated on the future event